Піонерські краватки, портрет Леніна,
уроки морально-етичного виховання.
Директорка 95-ой криворізької гімназії Алла Шепілко
показує фото тодішнього 7-Б класу.
Посередині - нинішній кандидат у президенти України Володимир Зеленський.
Українською мовою написано "класна робота",
хоча російськомовний клас. У нас гімназія була
тільки російськомовна на той час.
У гімназії Зеленським відверто пишаються -
інколи, можливо, надміру, - і кажуть, що
не пригадують нічого компрометуючого про школяра Володю Зеленського.
Алла Шепілко викладала в його класі математику.
Каже, цей предмет нинішній кандидат у президенти України знав на "відмінно".
Директорка показує нам оцінки його атестату
в журналі з архіву школи - для тих,
кому не подобається, що Зеленський часто
говорить російською, а не державною українською.
- У нього тільки "четвірка" з української,
російської мови, хімії та фізкультури.
Все решта - "відмінно". Це, як ми тоді говорили, "хорошист".
Це клас, у якому вчився Зеленський.
На другій парті середнього ряду. Ось тут.
Вчителі постійно згадують, як Зеленський
вже тоді смішив весь клас. Але одразу додають, що
уроків не зривав і батьків у школу не викликали.
Чи може він бути серйозним президентом?
У його гімназії переконують: так.
Вони запам’ятали Зеленського як неформального лідера класу,
який завжди мав власну думку і міг ії відстояти.
Різкі заяви на межі коректності - спосіб, в який
кандидат у президенти Зеленський спілкується з опонентом.
Вчителі Зеленського не кажуть, що про це думають.
Лише що він був чемним учнем з інтелігентної родини.
Родина Зеленських мешкала напроти цирку,
в 95-му житловому кварталі Кривого Рогу.
Звідси й назва його проекту.
Мурашник - так у Кривому Розі називають
цей величезний комплекс багатоквартирних будинків.
Саме тут своє дитинство провів
кандидат у президенти України Володимир Зеленський.
Тут і досі мешкають його батьки.
Батько Зеленського,професор місцевого інституту,
від інтерв’ю відмовився. А місцеві відгукуються про нього позитивно.
- Знала, поки тут жив.
Такий діяльний був, приємний мужчинка.
Валерію Івановичу 73. Каже, що Вова Зеленський -
точна копія його батька, людина "суворих правил".
Згадує, як маленький Зеленський часто виходив до дорослих грати в шахи.
Так донедавна робив і його тато,
поки не почалися президентські перегони.
- Якщо стане президентом, то в нас тут буде все добре,
тому що цей товариш не бере хабарів, нічого.
Як тато його принциповий, вихований
ще за соціалізму-комунізму, так і Вова - хороший товариш.
На вечірніх посиденьках у дворі політика - головна тема.
- За Зеленскього, тільки не за Порошенка.
- Його вчили танцювати, декламувати, розмовляти.
А ось якби його готували в президенти - це була б інша справа.
Володимир Зеленський закінчив юрфак
Криворізького економічного інституту.
Один із його викладачів, професор Іван Копайгора,
спершу здивувався наміру колишнього студента балотуватися.
Але каже, що отриманих тоді знань у разі перемоги
на виборах Зеленському має вистачити.
- Більше всього любив три дисципліни:
конституційне право України,
підприємницьке право
й інформаційне право.
Дипломну захистив з інформаційного права.
78-річний професор ображається за свого студента,
що того називають маріонеткою олігарха Коломойського.
Попри журналістські розслідування
про людей Коломойського в передвиборчому штабі Зеленського,
попри факти використання штабом кандидата
ресурсів олігарха і його команди професор переконаний:
його студент може бути незалежним політиком.
Олена Опанасенко закінчила ту ж 95-ту гімназію,
що й Зеленський, і особисто знала Володимира:
його клас мав шефство над молодшими.
Олена згадує, як уся школа, насамперед дівчата,
закохувалися в хлопців з Клубу Веселих і Кмітливих.
Уже тоді учні вважали Зеленського зіркою,
як і теперішні виборці, які захоплюються серіалом "Слуга народу".
- Із тих шкільних років, коли
клас Зеленського, коли ті діти
виходили на сцену, вони вже тоді створювали якісь певний сценічний образ, з тих юних років.
Наскільки цей образ співпадав із тим, хто це як людина?
Наскільки цю людину зараз знають виборці?
І взагалі люди, які бачать це по ТБ і в інтернеті?
Це велике питання.
У Кривому Розі, де Зеленський переміг у всіх трьох округах,
мало хто себе про це запитує.
Тим паче, що Зеленський категорично ухиляється
від численних прохань преси зі всього світу.
Він спілкується з виборцями відеороликами
і повідомленнями в соцмережах, а замість нього
на ток-шоу виступають його представники.
Аліна Фіалка-Смаль із цікавістю спостерігає
за перебігом цієї кампанії. Колись вона грала
в одному з криворізьких театрів і також була знайома з Зеленським.
Проте театр Аліни розпався, а проект Зеленського став успішним бізнесом.
- Ви ж знаєте, що короля робить оточення.
От, припустимо, Володимир стає президентом.
Команда! От наскільки ця павутинка буде
з порядних людей, як Вова, - ось тоді, може щось і зрушиться.
У дворі, де провів дитинство Володимир Зеленський,
ще не всі визначилися, за кого голосуватимуть.
Чекають, коли ж оголосять склад його команди
та якими будуть передвиборчі дебати.
Не всім подобається й те, як штаби обох кандидатів
спілкуються між собою. Дехто каже: якби знав,
голосував би не за Зеленського. І не за Порошенка,
який у Кривому Розі в першому турі посів
аж четверте місце після сина мера міста
Олександра Вілкула і колишнього члена команди Януковича Юрія Бойка.